Why.
Right.
That's right. That's right.
Ok. My name's eddie booth's.
I'm an architect
and an environmental activist
i suppose you could call me.
I've been living in this area for
18 years. In fact. Arrived here.
The year after the aquarius festival.
We were in fact i was seized during the
aquarius festival travelling through
southeast asia and other places on
to europe and then back again and
when we arrived back from.
From a trip all our friends were telling
us about the aquarius festival.
And prior to are overseas
trip we'd already decided to
get out of sydney.
We were living in sydney i had a practice
architectural practice in sydney and.
I wasn't very satisfied with
my practice or my lifestyle
and we wanted to move into the country.
We felt that we could.
Do some things
that we weren't able to do in the
city basically live a more laid back
lifestyle unpolluted that was
fear. We were living in balmain.
And we had the colgate palmolive factor.
You're right next to us which used to belch
huge billowing clouds of black smoke
out every night. Not during
the day only at night.
And we sort of felt we
were suffocating a bit.
Even though it was a pleasant place to
live in balmain in lots of other respects.
So we'd already made up our minds that
we were going to leave the city and
and set up somewhere in the country
but we are no idea where we were going to
in fact travel around australia looking
for a place. So anyway when we
came back from from our seas trip.
As i said before our friends were talking
about their queries first of all
and nimbin so we thought
well we'll check out nimbin
first before we do the rest of australia
and so we came while
still living in sydney.
We we made an excursion up here
and sort of fell in love with
the place immediately and.
Found quite a lot of people post aquarius.
People who'd decided to stay on a
timetable and various other places.
And so then we made a
decision there and then
that this was where we'd come to and.
We found a house and land we found
that the house and balmain which we
still owed money on but we found
that we could sell that
and for the proceeds we could buy
this piece of land here in nimbin
and. And we'd have a bit
of change left i would.
Tide us through until
hopefully we got some income.
So that's how we came to be here.
I'm in 1974 the year of the big.
Lismore flood.
All our belongings arrived in lismore
and went into hensley's storage depot
which was perched above the river.
And and the floods came and the
river rose and rose and rose
and we thought our stuff
was going to float away.
It came to within an inch within an
inch of our belongings and then.
Thankfully receded. So that was
our introduction to nimbin wet.
That was the first years were very wet.
The piece of land and the house that
we'd bought already had occupancy in it.
People who'd been renting
or squatting camping.
But we all fitted in very nicely together.
We live we we lived in
shared a house basically.
And. Started life in the country.
We were totally inexperienced we were
charged up with a lot of idealism and.
We had lots of ideas about
what we wanted to see happen
but we had very little eye idea of the
reality of living in the country.
So the first few years were really
discovering what it was all about.
Starting up gardens and orchards.
Rebuilding the house which was barely
livable in was a sort of rundown
country cottage.
But not not one of your classical veranda
places but a jerry built sort of joint.
And so we we started
rebuilding the house and.
And we got involved with what was
then quickly growing community
of new settlers from all over the country.
There were first of all
there were the people
that were left they were from their queries
first of all the ones who didn't even
bother leaving.
Or those who went went away and
reorganize themselves their affairs
and then came back to live here.
And from then on there was a stream
of people coming to the area
and most of us face similar
difficulties housing and
and and schooling
and so probably one of the first community
things we were involved in was.
Setting up the community school
which incidentally still operating.
So that. You know at least their vacation
part was going to be taken care of.
Our daughter.
Was 10 at 10 at the time i think.
And there were lots of other people
who are in a similar situation.
Mainly professionals or students
or you know young graduates very
highly qualified a lot actually.
Refugees from the cities
mainly sydney and melbourne
but other capital cities as well.
And so my first involvement
was the school.
Pretty soon along the way my next
sort of main interest became.
What became known as the home
builders association. Under the.
The circumstances
that we were facing here a lot of people
moved onto vacant blocks of land.
I think that's someone. Well. Right.
So yeah there were wet years
and people fight. Right in.
So in the 70s in the early 70s as
people were writhing here they were
finding that.
Often they were moving on to they
can pieces of land buying land
and buying into communities
and there was no housing for them
so they had pictured 10 and.
And very rudimentary shelters and and.
Try and cope with the weather
the leaches and the ticks and
and all the rest of it and so shelter
became a very important first step.
Getting them getting set up so that
you were out of the weather. And. So.
People generally came
with very little capital.
They couldn't afford to get
someone to build them a house
that was almost always
totally out of the question.
So what people did was they
became owner builders they.
Bought and scavenged materials
bought second hand stuff
and scavenged it wherever
they could find it
and used poles and. You
know which they did.
They'd cut trees. On their properties.
And they use these materials
to put up their houses. Now.
And they were very innovative
and. Very interesting ha's it's.
However the castle didn't
find them innovative
or interesting they found a total
affront to their regulations.
And. So.
While for quite a while they turned a blind
eye because they didn't really know how
to cope with it.
But then there was a police
raid on a on a property.
The rainier way or any of the
wallace road actually and.
It was to do with marijuana. And.
I can't remember whether there
were drugs on the place or not
but as a result of it. The police
made a complaint to the council.
Saying that this property had more
buildings on it than were permitted.
And because of the police complaint
that the council was obliged to send
their inspectors out which they did
and the inspectors inspected
the buildings. And it was.
They found
that there were three three more buildings
on the site than were allowed and
that the buildings didn't comply with
regulations in various ways you know maybe
the ceiling height wasn't quite right
or they might have had a loft in
them which in those days lofts were
recognised. And so.
They asked the owners of the
property to demolish the excess
houses and fix up what was
left to meet regulations.
Now these people weren't prepared to do
that they'd put a lot of love an effort
into building their shelters and.
Had no intention of
demolishing any of them.
And eventually things came to a
head they had a number of warnings
and then the next thing was the council
issued them with a demolition order which
said if you don't demolish we're
going to come out and do it for you.
Well they they got in touch with friends
and pretty soon the network of new settlers
in the area were alerted to what was
about to happen and most of us were
in very similar circumstances.
So we had a meeting in the in the media
centre which is where we are now.
And a hundred people turned up
and we formed the home builders association
which was initially it was formed to.
To stop council from going
ahead with the demolition.
And then grew to be an organisation
that generally fostered
and assisted the process of
home building in the area.
Did a lot of community projects we
organise work gangs work days on various
properties put up places and.
Add facilities and so on
and we opened negotiations
with it with the council.
And so. A group of us.
Carry these negotiations on with
council for quite a number of years.
No buildings wherever demolished and.
Gradually we we convinced council with
the systems of the state government.
Excuse me who were very.
Sympathetic to our cause and
i'll come to that in a minute.
With this instance of the state
government we we have we got implemented
multiple occupancy planning
regulations which.
Recognized more than the
prescribed number of buildings.
Acreage that. That was in the in the
in the regulations at that time.
Recognize the need allowed
more buildings and.
And we also started to get
council loosened up on some of
their interpretations of building bylaws
as as regards materials things like
mud brick.
Recycled material pole
frames and stuff like that
and also we we got them
to recognize a lot of by.
We were allowed to build
lofts because we had
but we had to call them storage
spaces. But then we'd sleep in them.
And i think nimbin sort of pioneered
the loft we you know there are so
many houses
that we lofts in them because they're
very handy way of utilizing space.
I mean we had to confront them on a whole
range of building issues you know for
instance it was one house
that didn't have a wall.
Now as far as the council's concerned
you cannot have a house without a wall.
You must have a wall.
So when when is a wall a wall
and when is a blank space or
or a tree or or. A vine.
When does that because.
I'm a wall an enclosed
space. So we had these.
Ridiculous arguments with them
about matters of the hour.
During all this time we had
terrific input from people in
sydney university and.
They helped us with the whole process
of getting multiple occupancy happening
and the loosening up of the regulations
and recognition of other building forms
other than the normal ones the council was
used to so.
Let's see. I've got to i've
got to draw my breath. Going.
So now we had a lot of help
from the state government.
And at that time it was neville
wran and the labor government
and then and there was a
particularly sympathetic minister.
For planning for land.
Unfortunately died a few
years ago a young man.
And. He was he was.
Quite enthusiastic about what we
were doing and very supportive.
So he helped change the
state planning laws.
Paul land it was also involved in.
Another matter of great
interest to us at the time.
And
and this is this is my other one of my
other great passions if you can call it
that. Which relates to
the environment. Now.
In in the early in the midst. Even these.
A group of new settlers in terrain here.
Became aware
that the forest at the end of their
valley the virgin rainforest
that there in the end of their
daily was about to be logged.
And they began to organize resistance
to it generally trying to persuade the
forestry commission of the following
folly of that course of action.
They weren't successful the forestry
commission is pretty intractable now in those
days they were totally
a law unto themselves
and weren't into any public
input whatsoever. So.
They were unsuccessful their campaign went
on for a number of years until in 1979.
The bulldozers started moving in.
Again this network of
people was alerted and.
Hundreds of us from around the
valleys nearby to rainier
and the people into rainier itself.
Went to the forest and
blockaded the bulldozers.
I think most people have
probably heard about rainier.
And it was probably the first major
environmental direct action in
australia. And it set the pace and
and the style of many future
environmental actions
for me it was a real.
I opened because i'd been aware of
rainforests when i'm. Moved up here.
I became aware of rainforests
they were you know around us
and i'd sort of had a look here and there.
But i didn't really know what they
were about and the terrain here.
Protest. Really.
Crystallized all these environmental
concerns because here was he was a
rainforest which i discovered was one of
the most cop complex ecosystems on the
planet.
With an amazing diversity
of flora and fauna.
We lived in the forest
during this protest.
We were there all the time we were
in and out we were up and down trees
and we were in front of the bulldozers
and we were running off into the forest
and playing chasing us
with the police and.
And this went on for a number of weeks.
So there was a there was this
mass conversion of people to
the defence of the rainforest people just
really got turned on to what rainforest
was about. And. And for me it.
It led to an involvement in
rainforest protection from
that time onwards.
And poor land that was. I started this
off by saying poor land was involved.
Well poor land again.
Gave support to the two are.
Our pleas for protecting the forest
and well this is history now
that the logging was stopped.
An enquiry was set up.
Which dragged on for a year
and spent a million dollars
and was never really used the results
of it were never really used by
that time other events caught
up with with three ania.
And. Fairly soon after.
All those areas became part of.
What eventually became world
heritage areas. In 1982.
There was a similar.
Similar forest protest here
in the nightcap range.
Well i think it did i think it
did not. Well nimbin nimbin.
You could say became the front
line of environmental defense.
Of the terrain a protest came other
similar protests. The nightcap.
Range middle head beach.
This was this wasn't the rainforest forest
matter this was sand mining a virgin.
Beach on the on the north coast.
But it was again it was driven
by the protest was driven by.
Concern
that here was a pristine environment
being destroyed for short term profit.
And im. I mean they were also. They were
extracting minerals which were going into.
Atomic warheads and so on.
So there were all these other aspects
involved and we were very much against
that that campaign incidentally was
lost the beach of the beach was mine.
The forests of the.
The forest and
that you as with destroyed.
Also in 1982. While the nightcap
protests this happening.
Tasmanian tasmania. The.
The franklin was under threat
and the tasmanian environmentalists were
starting to get organised to see what they
could do and they were very
interested in what we were doing here
and they sent representatives here to
talk to us and see what we were doing
and we kept in constant
touch until until in.
Must be in late 1980 to work started
on the franklin and the
blockade of the franklin began.
And many people from here.
Well perhaps like myself.
They. Packed their kids.
A few belongings into comedy
vans and other vehicles
and made the trek down to tassie.
And then spent three months on the river.
And we we had we had a lot to offer.
Well we were expecting the sort of
front line if you like to call it
that we were we went to the
blockade on the river.
The tasmanian wilderness
society organised the rest.
They they got the boats together they trained
people in nonviolent action they had
camps they organized supply and
lines radio communications.
It was a beautifully done. Job. And.
We did our part by doing the work upfront.
With the police and the workers and and
the barges that came up the river.
And of course educated and another
generation almost you could say of.
Of young australians.
Because it was it was holiday time
and students from all over the country
came to help with the blockade.
And we they had this crash course
of environmental awareness
and environmental action.
And of course then.
That campaign went on to 1983.
Until the labour government one office
and put a stop to. Well they didn't
actually quite put a stop to it but.
Signalled their intention to stop work.
And there was followed a protracted legal
process in the high court eventually
stopping. The destruction
of the destruction.
Can we pause for a minute.
Yes.
Quite true. I hope. You are right.
Well i think it's quite true that.
Nimbin has been. The breeding
ground of green extremists.
Yes
and i think that's one of its major
contributions to strain in society.
I mean if you look back. If you look
now the 20 years since aquarius.
There's been an enormous leap in.
Environmental awareness
throughout the whole country.
It's now mainstream that awareness.
It wasn't there 20 years ago and and i
think nimbin played a very people in them
and played. Played a major role in
getting that awareness happening.
And continuing it. And i hope will
continue to play a role in the future.
So yes.
There they can be labelled as extreme
as we can be labeled as extremists
but we feel
that these are extreme times i mean
what we saw was it was unbridled
exploitation of of resources
natural resources which.
Really the commonwealth. They're
not there to be taken by.
Vested interests someone out
there for a quick buck.
They belong to all of us
they belong to our children.
And we weren't prepared
to stand by and and.
You know see see them pillaged and raped.
Absolutely no apologies. Big thing.
There's a lot.
So the vision the vision.
You know 20 years ago and
and the years since then broadway eaves
of new settlers all bringing their
ideals and visions for the for the.
For the future
and i've mentioned.
I've mentioned home building
and then via im and as.
Some of the things that
people got involved in.
Well there were lots of other visions they
really spread across the whole spectrum
of human activity and endeavor.
And and ranging from home birth.
For instance birthing. We
wanted to see are kids born.
In a dress free nonclinical
thing environment. So.
Home birthing
and again we're sitting in the
building where home birthing was born.